we're going to begin with a growing
shift in the fight against the pandemic
as more states blue states in particular
are pulling back on their mass mandates
as daily covet cases drop
democratic governor gavin newsom is
ending california's indoor mass mandate
later this month among vaccinated people
another democratic governor phil murphy
of new jersey has announced an end to
school mass mandates starting next month
and several other states are doing the
same overall now 15 states in washington
d.c have a k-12 mass mandate in place
on the flip side eight states have
banned those mandates nationwide this of
course has been a fiercely debated topic
at school board meetings it's going out
to nikki batista who spoke to some
parents nikki i'll tell you i know new
york is on the fence about school
mandates but parents are increasingly
pro-vaccine but anti-mass particularly
for kids
tony good morning this is really a
difficult decision for parents new
york's mandate will expire this week and
the governor is expected to make an
announcement wednesday about possibly
ending it completely but with low
vaccination rates among children some
parents say the benefits of a mask-free
classroom do not outweigh coveted risks
this is a huge step back to normalcy for
our kids new jersey governor phil murphy
said his decision to drop a statewide
school mass mandate is not a declaration
of victory over the virus we're not
going to manage covid to zero we have to
learn how to live with covid from the
first week of january to the last week
of the month new student coveted cases
in new jersey dropped by nearly 80
percent and new staff cases were down by
more than 83 percent that drop in cases
is a national trend too with the
seven-day national average of cases more
than 60 percent lower than january's
peak it's why some health experts are
suggesting it might be time to ease some
restrictions especially with tools like
vaccines available you have a lot of
people who've been infected who have
some level of immunity for a period of
time and you have high vaccination rates
we can start to lean forward and take a
little bit more risk but many parents
are still concerned as only about 22
percent of children aged 5 to 11 are
fully vaccinated significantly lower
than the nearly 75 percent of adults it
seems to be a recipe for disaster
sending them in without masks on sabila
khan's two children are first and fourth
graders in jersey city new jersey's
public school district i think it's
premature right now to start talking
about
getting rid of masks health is a lot
more than just kobe dr carol vidal a
child psychiatrist at johns hopkins says
it is time for students to take off
their masks because so many have fallen
behind how does a parent weigh the risk
of covid versus the risk of educational
emotional
social developmental loss it's really
hard to measure right now the effects of
masking all the time i would expect that
we would find that it's going to be
causing harmful
effects because we are not designed to
to communicate with masks but for khan
whose children lost their grandfather to
the virus in 2020 the threat of covid
outweighs those risks i'm much more
concerned about
their mental health as
as it relates to covet loss and their
stresses around hovid
it's important to note that ultimately
the the decision whether or not to
require masks is up to each respective
school district the cdc's current
guidelines still recommend mass for all
school students teachers and staff the
white house yesterday said it supports
the cdc's guidelines but reiterated that
the decision is up to the districts
which has led to a patchwork of rules
throughout the pandemic gail it's great
to see the covet numbers going down
thank you very much nikki